mon nom est Barnabas Collins
il y a deux siècles j'ai fait de Collinwood ma maison
mon amour jusqu'à ce qu'une sorcière jalouse me maudit
me condamnant à l'ombre pour
toujours qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'il vient
écoutez-moi futur habitant quelle est l'année
dix-neuf sous-réseau toi 1972 pourquoi bien-aimé
Famille Collinwood Collins l'enfer est-
ce ouais tu restes avec nous pour toujours
bienvenue à la maison Barnabas Collins bientôt
les Xhosas peuvent-ils être prêts nous n'avons pas de chevaux
nous avons une Chevy quelle sorcellerie est-ce
que c'est révèle-toi petite chanteuse bonjour
Barnabas souviens-toi de moi que tu m'as maudit
être cette créature hideuse maltraiter
facilement placez vos merveilleuses lèvres sur mon
postérieur et embrassez-le à plusieurs reprises mais si
je vous ai fait m'aimer avec quel sort
avec ça je dois admettre qu'ils n'ont pas
vieilli d'un jour
elle pour de vrai en effet
je ne peux pas sucer pour  vous et votre famille
m'avez manqué
je redonnerai à l'entreprise familiale
sa gloire d'
antan  tonique ou quelque chose qu'ils ont essayé de
me lapider mon cher ça n'a pas marché